ladies if you're looking to switch up
your look in 2021
then lauren zema has the main makeover
tricks to help you get it
christine we want to say new year new me
and that often means new hair right how
much do people change their hair with
the new year
you're so right on i feel like the
second i can feel
january first coming i'm like oh god
let's get ready everybody
there's lots of fringes lots of planks
give me a bang i always think that a
fringe is a big commitment
so i almost tell my clients i would
prefer you to like take up the length
three or four inches
okay unless you're absolutely sure you
really want that new step in the morning
having to blow dry your fringe
so how else can you freshen up your look
this new year
we teamed up with celebrity hairstylist
christine simons and hot tools to
inspire your new styles
hot tools has their signature series one
step blowout detachable volumizer
and depending on your hair type your new
hair length your hair textured whatever
style you can imagine you can achieve
with one of their three
detachable brush heads so you've done
some looks here for us today
take us through look number one so look
number one was really fun because she
turned her curly
slightly frizzy hair into a smooth
voluminous blowout in a matter of
minutes so look number two
her hair was a little different her hair
tends to dry naturally with a little
wave in it
so we used the straight dry paddle brush
to give her that shine
i love hot tools because it's a brand
that's been around for 30 years and it's
specifically designed
and engineered for stylists but from a
stylist
to just a gorgeous woman wanting to do
her hair everybody can get their hands
on it